ça fait deux fois de suite images à vous
j'avoue d'amour aujourd'hui je vais le
défoncer suis entraîné toute la nuit
j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
je peux vous dire j'ai vu s'entraîner
voilà je suis à fond oui il est avec
nous ce soir
merci d'accueillir le champion dominique
non
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
ah ah
m
[Applaudissements]
il a fait venir une star internationale
ça manquait des surveillants c'est un
truc de ouf merci d'être là ce soir
spécial années 90 merci d'être là et je
vous dis on fait partie de la tournée
born in 90 qui passera par les zénith de
france à partir du 31 octobre à rouen
dijon tout ça et franchement merci
d'avoir été là où kiffe ce titre merci
[Applaudissements]
il est là
et je crois qu'il y a le président des
états unis
kid à une allocution à faire avant notre
combat regardez je tiens à témoigner
tout mon soutien assuré là nous
n'arrivons cette période sombre et
difficile et je tiens surtout à lui dire
que les états unis feront tout pour
l'aider à éliminer cette gamine
communiste jeu bénisse l'amérique et
cyril anwar force à toi mes bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
connue
dominique et a déjà gagné racée jours
dominique qui a déjà gagné une ps4 et
dominique qui joue aujourd'hui
bon un magnifique vélo ou un magnifique
vélo électrique nouveau et c'est de là
qu'on va de leurs mots le sait le veut
absolument un vélo électrique de ouf les
cherry and on n'en fera finalement c'est
une télé mais c'est une télé que tu vois
tu je revois un micron tu vois tout ça
ça peut être toi tu vois les cracks ah
bon ça peut être à toi ça ça peut être à
toi un peu qu'à toi alors
[Applaudissements]
portable je rappelle que ça se joue avec
un smartphone et un looser mairie n'a
vraiment moi ça y'est bébé alors tu vas
tout est un peu de son côté derek et va
tourner un peu et oui hein pourquoi je
suis pas des raquettes un cieux il a
fait trois séries vous perdez on ouvrira
l'émission avec ça exactement
d'accord se plaire je sais les
spectateurs d'être avec nous ce match ça
va être encore un match sans merci
téléphone en garde ses montagnes je veux
jouer combien 5 10 20 ou 200 points bas
20 noms ont 10 points sur 10 points mais
tes fans de bb étoiles est oui
torse nu dominique quet pour moi
[Applaudissements]
quoi
le
étant donné que cet indice il n'y a pas
de balles d'échauffement démarre dial
diop dominique suis derrière toi série
est un looser
tapha l'impression à nos eaux
il est encombrant de vénissieux paix et
à dia du retard sur les points bas de 1
pour moi attends attends à les médias
mais que de quatre jours du nom
al'inverse ces fonds dominique est de 1
oui
[Applaudissements]
ouais aujourd'hui trois fois tu es au
crotoy machine
téléspectateurs et merci de la classe 2
on le fait des scores et ça va faire des
scores bordel amétélé bien surtout à huy
3 2 3 2 pour moi de venir promettent eux
la raconte pas ça
[Applaudissements]
pour bon ok il est mort il avait journal
c'est plus facile quand tu as peut tirer
champions c'est tout et walker
[Applaudissements]
abdellaoui 5,3 pour moi est souple et 5
pour la toux sur la verte sur la croatie
ma poule passion c'est andy je rappelle
pour nos téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent et
[Applaudissements]
dominique cbc il donne des points
il a perdu son mojo passé de losers
winner ça sent la salle et la table est
courte
vas-y mon dos chez soi alain view
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai surtout à dominique semer des
clous joue pas en reculant à l'angola
bol des coupes âme à ce point est
important
super se doit avec shoah pour toi tu
n'es pas de la pression et pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce recul avance je suis avant tout
humaines dominique alors c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
en vingt points
dominique tu peux le faire mais oui ces
deux bals gratuits pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent à deux balles de match pour
la personne ne va pas trop stressé non
seulement tu l'as déjà battu dominique
c'est tout bête c'est une grande gueule
sache que tu auras des pouvoirs qu'on
travaille bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un truc à proposer à oui je
t'explique
pour l'instant tu as week-end et tu as
ta playstation tu vas faire vu l'écran
que j'offre bien entendu un
téléspectateur hashtag écran loser
dominique dominique où tu me dis je
reviens lundi
mais si je perds je perds tout ou bien
tu me dis non je repars avec ça je suis
bien content pour tes couilles le dos
par contre lundi il y aura un autre
cadeau en jeu et je peux te le dire ça a
été un cadeau exceptionnel
ça sera le vélo électrique dont je t'ai
parlé quand on veut aller au devant du
flash d'adobe le vélo amérique société
avant tu devrais mais c'est bien on voit
bien là dit qu'est ce que tu dis je
reviens hier
[Applaudissements]